if you get a house and you take one
brick out of that house it'll still
stand but it'll be weakened if you take
two bricks there it'll still stand but
it will be weakened subsequently you can
take enough bricks out until it
collapses and it will still be stood up
and it will look to all intents and
purposes fine but it won't be strong
it's exactly the same thing with
biodiversity
the fact of the matter is we're
currently facing a conservation crisis
more and more species are at risk of
going extinct every single day and many
species are lost without even being
known to science if we look at this some
planet that we live on this wall
floating around it's got this fantastic
regulating system that regulates the
climate the water the air all these
things that we take for granted but the
nonce and the bonds of the system are
the species within it the pied tamarind
for example the black line tempers the
fish they're all part of the machine
that keeps us on this habitable planet
so if we start chucking away the nuts
and bolts I almost don't disappear in
ultimately you know from a selfish point
of view that's gonna have an impact on
us yeah it's kind of a massive impact on
us
every day more and more species are
threatened with extinction and the money
raised from the project for Austin would
make a colossal difference to a small
organization like Durrell but it's
trying to stem a global tide Darryl's
mission is saving species from
extinction and that's something that's
been the mission ever since the trust
was established in 63 we are a
fast-moving adaptive organization that
rush in like like the accident emergency
conservation that rush in when a species
really needs somebody to try and restore
it I've been lucky enough to work with
Darryl here in Jersey for a few days and
frankly these have been some of the best
days of my life being able to work with
people who are passionate about the idea
of conservation you know deer saving
species from extinction and just have an
affinity with life on this planet it's
not like any other place in the world I
can say that with my hand on my hair and
it's mainly due to the people that
they're attracted here nobody's here for
the wages people are here because they
care and I think it shows you don't see
species here that we don't think we can
keep in captivity I defy anybody to go
to a big cat exhibit anywhere in the
world and see and not see an animal pace
in so for that reason you won't see big
cats you don't see much megafauna the
keepers here all have misgivings about
captivity yes as Gerald Daryl said in an
ideal world we wouldn't need animals in
captivity
need endangered species in captivity but
we're far from that at the moment and we
need them and people need to get behind
the good sues that do conservation work
and support them I'd like to say that
we're probably the most effective
conservation organization in the world
for our size and the data stirrers seem
to back that up
we've undoubtedly undoubtedly saved two
species from extinction some of the most
threatened species in the world of
Mauritius Kestrel was down to four
individuals and only one breeding pair
through pioneering techniques like
double-clutching and soft release all
under Cal Jones is kind of tenure that's
gone up to now around 600 in the world
the Rodriques fruit bat rotaries flying
fox was down to 65 individuals and one
tree and it was brought back to Durrell
in the 70s now I think there's around
10,000 in captivity and a 4,000 in the
wild so you know there's that's this
multiple species that are only here
because of Durrell da wall is a small
organization and it will always stay
that way in order to provide the most
effective point conservation care but
the funds from the project for awesome
would allow them to do their jobs so
much better and expand their reach to
the species which they feel need their
help
it may huge difference if we had any
injection of a hundred thousand pounds
for example that would allow us to run
five if not six workshops in Brazil that
was means where we pay for the
participants the poor Brazilian
colleagues to come organize the workshop
support the field that's going on for
years to come you've got to remember
100,000 pounds will go a long way in
some of these range countries for
example the Chamorro islands Madagascar
when working with the Alouette and
gentle Vemma the Lima that's only found
in one Marsh area in Madagascar one of
the things we do as an organization is
enable the passionate people on the
ground
to keep going here's why you should vote
for Darrell for the project for awesome
because the message here the message of
this place and this organization is the
most important I think of any charity in
the world the work that is done here is
being done to save the soul of this
planet it's being done to preserve the
biodiversity to preserve habitats all
across the world and to safeguard
everything that we enjoy about this
planet for our children our children's
children it's our responsibility to
protect those species and we for future
generations to see you know let's not
let them not be just myths and stories
that we tell our kids in the future you
know riah's once exists in it in Africa
we can do something about it now let's
do it you know because we only have one
planet we can't just up stick some move
to Mars if we screw up earth that's it
we've lost all of this and I think it's
worth fighting for and it's worth
supporting that's why you should vote
the dollar for the project for awesome